Kevin Feige and his merry band of Marvel
movie makers brought down the house at
San Diego comic-con 2019 to a sea of
buzzing fans Marvel Studios announced a
shining Slater face for movies and
television series set to launch over the
next two years
everything from the Jane Foster
featuring Thor love and thunder to a
shang-chi movie to a bunch of Disney
Plus superhero shows what was missing
from the jam-packed panel though was the
announcement of another Avengers movie
which some fans were holding out hope
for thanks to pass rumors a suggested
Marvel was cooking up a 5th and sambal
film featuring Earth's Mightiest Heroes
in the aftermath of Marvel's
presentation studio president Feige
revealed to IGN the reason why Avengers
5 wasn't announced at San Diego
comic-con simply put us because there'll
be no Avengers 5 as far as Feige is
concerned the era of Avengers films as
we know them concluded with Avengers
endgame Feige explained and now it's
time to the Marvel Cinematic Universe to
move on to new superhero stories it
isn't necessarily out with the old but
it's certainly in with the new when it
comes to phase 4 of the MCU Feige
explained we had a movie this year
called Avengers endgame and it is very
much an ending as you saw to so many of
those characters so phase 4 is about
beginnings and phase 4 it's about
learning new things about characters you
already think you know like Black Widow
meeting incredible new characters are
the Eternals and shang-chi going on new
adventures with Doctor Strange and Thor
and these Disney Plus shows which I
promise will be spectacular and not
where anybody's expecting Feige isn't
saying that the past needs to die and
the Marvel should never acknowledge the
Avengers again but it's clear that he
wants Marvel fans to understand that a
new chapter of the MCU is meant to be
just that new there was not easy to let
go and say goodbye to heroes you've
watched evolve for years and while it
will take some time for everyone to
fully recover from the events of
Avengers and game there's really nothing
to do but given to change right read it
run from it destiny arrives all the same
and now it's here okay well maybe that
guys are the best person to think for
the slovak advice from anyway Earth's
Mightiest Heroes very well might round
up again but it won't happen in phase
four and the potential ensemble flake
will feature a different roster likely a
blend of older Marvel mainstays and
fresh faces introduced in phase four and
there to be announced phase five
longtime Marvel star samuel l.jackson is
confident of this possibility and
believes that his character Nick Fury
were bound up the villain fighting
forces in the future asked by cinema
blend if he thinks that Avengers centric
movies should be shelved in favor of
team-up films like Spider Man far from
home which brought fury and new MCU
character Mysterio into Spidey solo
series Jackson said he doesn't agree he
elaborated saying that fury knows a
threat is heading to earth and that
he'll eventually need to create a new
crew of Avengers to defeat the imminent
danger I always think that there's room
for every kind of story to be told and
at some point they're going to have to
put together another Avengers group of
some sorts to deal with whatever's
coming next Nick Fury knows something is
coming the same way he found out in
Captain Marvel that there are other
things that need to be dealt with that
he didn't know about this is moving us
to another place so could we get a young
Avengers movie maybe perhaps a Dark
Avengers film yeah why not but a fifth
Avengers flick with the og Thorin cap
Iron Man and Black Widow Hawkeye and
Hulk well don't hold your breath
unless you're Nick Fury you never tell
Nick Fury he's wrong we get into a
situation like this again what happens
then
he'll come back
you really sure about that I am check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]